the prophet Muhammad S.I wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale
how are you guys doing I was recently
sent a video from a good friend of mine
of this guy called Constantine relating
a discussion a conversation that he had
with Ben Shapiro let's take a look at
the key points of contention and come
back and respond in kind and so to me
masculinity isn't about having big
muscles or having a big head or wide
fists or whatever uh if we think about
our conversation earlier about power
like I remember talking to Ben shapir
about this and he was like yeah there's
this guy on the internet who's like yeah
I could I could take I've got big muscle
he was like yeah I could pay people to
shoot you now I'll be honest with you
for more than one reason I found the
content of this video quite
disturbing now whether or not this Ben
Shapiro was talking about me the
muscular guy I think the people can make
that judgment themselves whether the
muscular guy is the champ
or it's not the jam but that's something
you can discuss later but the content of
the video where he was saying well I can
get someone to shoot him I've got a
question for you Ben if you're talking
about whether or not you're talking
about it's irrelevant and
immaterial here's my question for you
what would make you any different for my
wife or my child my daughter for example
if your only consequence as a man is to
pay another man to deal with your work
if that's your consequence as a man that
want makes you different from my wife or
my daughter what makes you any different
because that's the same consequence my
wife has or my daughter has my
10-year-old daughter she has the same
consequences as you do she can come to
me and and say that this person has
abused me this person has done this and
then I would defend her so what you're
actually admitting there is that you
don't have any consequence of your own
you're a doile man with limited
consequences that's the truth of the
matter and what I IAL the situation bro
as well I didn't tell you this but
what's ironical the situation is the
fact that this guy was speaking for
about 3 minutes prior about masculinity
and he and Constantine was talking for
about 3 minutes I couldn't get I've
heard this before what he was saying he
talking about the chimps and all these
kind of things things that you've heard
from Jordan Peterson effectively a copy
and paste of Jordan Peterson's um you
know discussion on the matter about Prim
chimps and this and
whatever and for some reason or another
he brought Ben shapir into a discussion
I I don't
[Laughter]
know let's let's be fair let's be fair
now you're talking about pay being paid
are you being paid to talk about Ben
Shapiro in the context of mascul because
I know for a fact he's trying to appear
like a man now done a rap video recently
huh he's trying to be he's trying to
appear like a
man he's trying to
maybe don't know what he's doing bro but
really and truly on a on a acade on an
academic level let's speak frankly what
is
masculinity because obviously we come
from different okay Traditions but
according to both of our Traditions
there's actually a very
similar
definition a very similar kind of like
theme if you like because if you look at
if you like the Western tradition and
obviously the Western tradition is not
one monolith but if you look at for
example The Classical period the
helenistic period the presocratic period
uh Plato AR zakian ethics Plato's
Republic all these kinds of things it
would seem to me that the main thing
that makes a man differentiates a man
distinguishes a man from his female
counterpart what really makes a man is
bravery that is the key
virtue key differentiating virtue that's
not to say that woman cannot be um Brave
it just means that men need to have this
virtue in more abundance than a woman
does so that they can enact the things
that they to an act as Warriors as
providers as protectors now this was
understood in fact the Greek
word Andreas or
effectively ma masculinity is the same
word for bravery and the same thing is
applicable in the Islamic tradition
because in the Islamic tradition the
prophet told
us that the worst thing in a man is from
to be stingy and for him to be a coward
so bravery clearly is the is the
main virtue which makes a man a man now
I want you to ask you a question or
anybody else a question what do you
think what evidence do we have that Ben
shipiro has manifested any level of
bravery in his life the most Brave thing
he's ever done is challenge college
students and that's not brave at all
because they're not his they're not
equals to him the debates he's had were
with people that were effectively
sympathetic to a lot of his world view
so he has not manifested that he should
not be in these
conversations and in fact recently his
friend Lex fredman has put a list of
major names including my own of course
of the pro Palestinian
side but I would have to say more senior
names people like Norman felstein people
like abdal andalusi who were on that
list and he has a choice of all these
people all of which have called him out
for a DE debate on the Palestine issue
one of his main bread and butter issues
and if you look at that list of the main
names that Lex Friedman without
consultation and other people have
recommended to
him you will realize that Ben Shapiro
has never ever debated those people on
that issue now is that really a display
of bravery and of
Valor I don't think so
I don't think so at all so he is a
coward and I think there's good evidence
for that the fact that this man is a
coward and I'm speaking now on honest on
a genuine level I think he's a coward I
think in fact Jordan Peterson with all
of the disagreements that we have with
him showed more
fortitude yes than he did in the fact
that he at least conversed with me he
had discussion he came face to face you
got to give him some Li credit at least
he stood in front I mean we just
completely disagree with the guy but Ben
Shapiro couldn't master
that let alone to go to someone like
Norman finlin who for 40 years has been
searching researching this topic and
would shred this man to Pieces
intellectually moreover I would like to
say that why on Earth would you even
mention H why on some on Earth would
someone like you even mention shooting
this person that person aren't your
Zionist counterparts doing enough of
that anyway to the children
shooting the children had I said I can
pay somebody else to shoot that that
would be front page news but that's
another story for another day suffice it
for me to say now suffice it for me to
say that unfortunately the Zionist
project and its proponents have shown
the most cowardice I've seen from
anybody ever
before and you as a proponent of that
are no different Ben Shapiro was
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a daa center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more